wenn es um ko tropfen geht sind die
schlagzeilen absolut verstörend und
schockieren die betroffenen sind
willenlos gelähmt oder gar bewusstlos
und können sich an nichts mehr erinnern
dann werden sie bestohlen oder opfer von
sexuellem missbrauch und die
dunkelziffer ist extrem hoch doch es
gibt möglichkeiten sich vor ko tropfen
zu schützen und sogar ein spezielles
armband das aber einen haken hat die zum
science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
eine sache ist ganz klar schuld haben
einzig und allein die täter doch viele
menschen die opfer von ko tropfen werden
schämen sich und suchen die schuld bei
sich selbst das ist einer der gründe
warum es keine verlässlichen statistiken
darüber gibt wie viele menschen pro jahr
opfern von ko tropfen werden
ich selbst habe mal wohl versehentlich
eine portion abbekommen der nächste
morgen war extrem seltsam aber manche
betroffenen merken es aber auch gar
nicht oder zu spät dass sie opfer von
ko-tropfen geworden sind im blut und
urin kann die substanz nur wenige
stunden nachgewiesen werden das
bundeskriminalamt geht von einer hohen
dunkelziffer aus die hilfsorganisation
weißer ring berichtet auf ihrer webseite
von solch einem schrecklichen fall als
nina frühmorgens in einem münchner park
zu sich kommt auf dem boden liegend die
kleidung verrutscht das lebt in den knie
gehen ist sie zunächst verwirrt an die
vergangenen stunden kann sie sich nicht
erinnern was sie noch weiß sie war in
einem club hat getanzt sich amüsiert mit
fremden geräten drinks ausgegeben
bekommen eigentlich ein ganz normaler
abend die bezeichnung ko-tropfen kommt
aus dem englischen knockout was so viel
heißt wie außer gefecht setzen
und das bringt es wirklich gut auf den
punkt ein kompletter blackout ist die
fatale folge vor allem der
gedächtnisverlust ist typisch und die
opfer können sich einfach an nichts mehr
erinnern
genau das macht es den tätern so leicht
oft mischen sie die tropfen in clubs
oder bars in getränke und in der party
stimmung bleibt das meist unbemerkt die
tropfen selbst sind geschmacksneutral
und zudem sind sie farblos so dass es
nicht möglich ist diese gefahr auf den
ersten blick zu erkennen und genau das
macht sie so gefährlich doch es geht
eben nicht nur ein ko mit den sondern
rund 8 140 substanzen die missbräuchlich
als solches eingesetzt werden können der
großteil dieser substanzen ist übrigens
legal
und wird sogar therapeutisch eingesetzt
beispielsweise als beruhigungs oder
schlafmittel durch eine überdosierung
und die heimliche gabe werden diese
substanzen anzuklopfen drei chemische
stoffe sind in diesem zusammenhang
besonders aufzuhören die substanz gbl
gamma-butyrolacton und video 1,4
butandiol die beide in europa legal sind
sowie das illegale ghb gamma hydroxy
buttersäure
letzteres ist illegal bei überdosierung
und in zusammenhang mit alkohol besteht
lebensgefahr
da ein atemstillstand hervorgerufen
werden kann doch es gibt möglichkeiten
sich vor ko-tropfen zu schützen wichtig
ist das glas oder die flasche nie
unbeobachtet zu lassen und keine offenen
getränke von unbekannten menschen
annehmen sobald man sich unwohl fühlt
sollte man bekannte freunde oder das
personal der location ansprechen und um
hilfe bitten
für kim eisenmann aus karlsruhe war das
aber nicht genug sie hat zusammen mit
ihrem freund ein spezielles armband
entwickelt mit dessen hilfe man drinks
auf bekannte ko-tropfen testen kann
in einem interview erklärt sie wie sie
auf die idee gekommen ist im vergangenen
sommer war ich mit meinem freund sven
auf einem stadtfest und dort wurde eine
bekannte von uns opfer von ko-tropfen
nachts wurde sie dann in einem park
gefunden sie konnte sich an nichts mehr
erinnern und war schlimm verletzt
das war für mich ein totaler schock weil
wir auch auf dem festwagen und es
genauso gut mich hätte erwischen können
die gefahr hat sich einfach so nah an
gefühlt man denkt immer mir und meinen
freunden kann so etwas nicht passieren
bis es dann doch passiert ein bekannter
dori markt hat kim eisenmans armband in
die vermarktung aufgenommen und die
nachfrage im onlineshop ist groß dass
ammann ist weiß und strahlt im
schwarzlicht der meisten klubs manche
täter werden im besten fall dadurch
schon abgehalten wenn man aber den
verdacht hat dass mit dem eigenen
getränk etwas nicht stimmt rührt man den
drink um und gibt einen tropfen auf das
testfeld des armbandes wenn k o tropfen
enthalten sind färbt sich das testfeld
blau ein armband reicht aus um zwei
getränke zu prüfen doch vorsicht der
haken denn längst nicht alle substanzen
werden mit diesem armband abgedeckt es
spricht nur auf den gängigsten typ von
ko-tropfen ghb an und ist somit kein
vollschutz gegen sämtliche drogen doch
eine weiterentwicklung ist geplant damit
auch andere stoffe erkannt werden können
auch die politik ist an dem thema dran
eine möglichkeit wäre das arznei- oder
betäubungsmittelgesetz zu ändern
um so den umgang mit entsprechenden
substanzen einzudämmen diskutiert wird
zudem auch die entsprechenden substanzen
mit bitterstoffen zu versetzen damit sie
unbedingt heraus geschmeckt werden
können dazu sozial und
integrationsminister manne luca nach der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz der länder
im juni diesen jahres 2009 10
wir haben das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
aufgefordert geeignete regelungen zu
treffen um die missbräuchliche
herstellung von ko-tropfen einzudämmen
wir müssen wege finden die
missbräuchliche verwendung von
substanzen die eigentlich zur
herstellung von medizinischen oder
industriellen produkten gedacht wagen zu
verhindern mindestens genauso wichtig
ist aber die prävention dazu ein
sprecher vom weißen bund den enkeltrick
gibt es inzwischen zum beispiel seit
mehr als 20 jahren und der funktioniert
immer noch wir müssen auch bei k -o
-tropfen dranbleiben und wo bekommt man
die k -o -tropfen zum beispiel internet
drogenkriminalität im darknet cooles
video vom breaking lab anklicken
anschauen und den ebenso coolen kanal
rating lab abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran